DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO THE
SEWER OF IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
-- SARA CARTER ON THE GROUND IN
VIRGINIA ASKING DEMOCRATS WHAT
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT BIDEN'S
TERRIBLE FIRST 9 MONTHS IN
OFFICE.
THIS WILL BE INTERESTING.
>> VERY INTERESTING.
PEOPLE SHOWED UP, BUT BECAUSE
GLENN YOUNGKIN AND TERRY
MCAULIFFE ARE NECK AND NECK WITH
ONLY 7 DAYS LEFT.
A LOT OF TERRY MCAULIFFE
SUPPORTERS ARE AVOIDING REALITY.
IT'S ABOUT TERRY MCAULIFFE
HIMSELF.
HIS SUPPORT FOR CRITICAL RACE
THEORY IN THE SCHOOLS.
HIS STATEMENTS HE MADE THAT
PARENTS SHOULD BE HANDS OFF ON
THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ANY CONCERN WITH TERRY
MCAULIFFE AND GLENN YOUNGKIN
GETTING SO CLOSE IN A STATE LIKE
VIRGINIA?
DO YOU THINK THAT MAYBE
MCAULIFFE'S ACTIONS IN THE
SCHOOLS WHEN HE SAID PARENTS
HAVE TO STAY OUT OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SYSTEM, THAT AFFECTED IT
A LITTLE BIT?
>> TERRY DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> THE WAY I LOOK AT PUBLIC
EDUCATION, WHILE PARENTS
INVOLVEMENT IS IMPORTANT.
IF THEY WANT MORE CONTROL OVER
THEIR CHILD'S CURRICULUM, THERE
ARE OTHER OPTIONS OTHER THAN
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
>> DO YOU THINK IT HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF PARENTS IN LOUDOUN
COUNTY AND ANY OF THAT, WITH THE
SCHOOLS AND WHAT MCAULIFFE SAID
ABOUT BEING HANDS OFF?
THAT COULD HAVE AFFECTED THIS
AGAIN.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> SEAN, SOME PEOPLE WERE RUDE
WHEN I PRESSED ON THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE.
THEY ARE BACKING TERRY MCAULIFFE
HERE BECAUSE THIS IS A BLUE
AREA.
THIS IS WHY BIDEN SHOWED UP
HERE.
ARLINGTON IS MORE BLUE THAN RED.
WHEN YOU TALK TO PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT GLENN YOUNGKIN, THEY
WILL SAY YOU WILL NEVER SEE
A RALLY LIKE THIS IN LOUDOUN
COUNTY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
SHOWED UP TONIGHT?
>> WELL, ESTIMATING AROUND 2000
PEOPLE.
THAT'S GIVE OR TAKE.
IT WAS EXTREMELY SMALL COMPARED
TO THE RALLIES WE SAW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OTHERS AND
BECAUSE THIS AREA IS SO BLUE.
WE EXPECTED A LOT MORE PEOPLE.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN DUE TO THE
CHILLY WEATHER.
WE DON'T KNOW.
BIDEN DID NOT DRAW IN THE CROWDS
EXPECTED TODAY AND NEITHER DID
TERRY MCAULIFFE.
>> Sean: DONALD TRUMP GOT CROWDS
OF 40,000 PEOPLE AND 30,000
OUTSIDE.
>> YES.
>> Sean: IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE YOU
GOT RECOGNIZED.
THAT'S GOOD PROBABLY IF YOU ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT SHOW IF
HOSTILE TERRITORY.
>> I W